you think your team that you played with
can be better than the team that i've
played with yeah that can't happen with
england anyone you played with oh oh
[ __ ] i've definitely won it
no i don't i've got shira i've got the
lot you got shearer have you no but i
got salah
how would you get him fiorentina firenze
oh my god
[Music]
yes micah gary how are we how is the
manchester city ambassador
oh he's a political leader
this week fantastic
sergio aguero's title winning goal is
the best moment in premier league
history
get your glass over there
get your glass over there is that for me
or in premier league as in
in my opinion look at how he was
scrambling he just doesn't want to give
c the credit
what is a better moment than that tell
me in premier league history what's
what's the better moment
i agree agree only agreed i strongly
agree i agree i agree it to me i was in
the stadium on that day i'm in the crowd
i'm thinking wow i'm in the best place
in the world united are going to win the
league and i'm in the stadium of city
and they're all crying underneath me and
my feet almost
and then that goal goes in and i've
never seen anything like it in my life
oh i do agree i do in terms of as a
neutral at the united father it was
horrible but as a neutral you're never
going to get better than that there's
only goal difference as well wouldn't it
that's what made it even worse
so i think you need to move it a little
bit
i've spoke about this day many times
before i was on the bench on a did you
come off the bench
no
honestly it hurts me why have you asked
this question
you played you played more than five
games to get a medal didn't you
[Laughter]
you
you're
no that season i've played the majority
of the season
how many games did you play on the game
honestly i played muller's up at 29. and
i was injured for what you binged you
for last game basically remember the
derby and all that matter the match i
think you could be mad at the match
remember maybe i was on absolute fire
banter aside
and then i pulled my hamstring as as
usual mancini didn't
change his team but when we used to go
one or two and up used to bring me on
the qpr what happened you're losing
losing yeah all the attacking players so
i'm there feeling sorry for myself
and who goes and scores the first goal
defender on it
it was like a it was like a ducker
and he called him he got carried he got
their balls avalanches the best small
bag i'm like i've played the whole
season city about to win the league and
basically he's on the bench they're
miserable
i was i was devastated roy keane was a
better leader than vincent company oh
i mean
look what sort of question is this
i wouldn't know i wouldn't know that
cause i didn't play with him one way
you're gonna lose an old mate or a new
mate
i've got a henchmen
[Applause]
how
against lester where's your statue vince
where do you want his statue vincent
company i remember the commentary yeah
he was under mate good line that one it
was fantastic he got it did he roy
keane's the most influential football
player i've ever seen by a million miles
in the premier league the most
influential tony adams is the only one
john terry
that
vincent comes up brilliantly that don't
get me wrong but honestly to me yeah boy
is it this for me though or just in
general you can answer that question
yourself monica
ah
[Applause]
roy's got that present so only
you don't want to mess with roy like
vincent company's
a lovely blow cute
little charm you won't need to call him
nice next
he's really nice vincent oh no
no but from where company came from
don't forget we was like fighting
relegation when he when he arrived the
season after
i mean i struggled i struggled with
management with indecision
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah i think but agree i agree i won't
strongly agree because
from where company started to where it
ended up vincent's on the phone
does it scare you a little bit roy on it
on a serious note when we were playing
there was definitely a fear element with
the younger lads roy was probably five
four five years old but he did ever he
did have a fear factor to him when when
uh but i got when you get used to him no
when you assume no i love him yeah i
think he's like you have to do it
gary neville's best ever team of players
he played with is better than michael
richards's team of players he played
with
behave yourself
let's go for it let's go for it right
now goalkeepers you've got big
schmeichel okay
i
[Laughter]
joe art was a top keeper in his in his
time schmeichel yeah longevity okay i'll
give you schmeichel yeah right back do
you think you were better than me on
your day
i don't think i would see you
oh let me zoom him right back oh well he
played left back
right back as well is this lee can i go
stuart pierce by the can is this england
as well
anyone you played with oh oh [ __ ] i've
definitely won it
no i don't i've got shira i've got the
lot you've got shear have you did you
play shira no but i've got salah
how would you get him
oh my god
come on let's go for the team oh my god
ronaldo rooney
up front i've got keane
scholes beckham giggs
lampard
i've got a city squad basically i've got
i i still think i can top that
you think your team no no just you might
have one player that can beat you no no
you think your team that you played with
can be better than the team that i
played with yeah that can't happen it
course it could be my cricket card
unfortunately i was privileged i was
carried by these guys i know
that's where you
oh okay i've got jt
i've got rio i play for england
yeah ashley cold simple i've got ronaldo
in his peak
oh i've got gigs i've played with him at
the uh olympics
it's a broad spectrum yeah you said if
you played with them gigs are playing
with gigs
yaya tori vieira david silva
these players by the way he played with
vieira again
it doesn't matter sir vincent company oh
my god
vincent corn is better than
vic some companies better stamp i mean
i've not even mentioned cantona hughes
cole york it's not bad is it no nice not
bad
i think it's a draw
i'll take a draw
all right okay
micah played with the same people as me
but when they were 38 i played them when
they were good
i didn't notice that
[Laughter]
england will win the world cup this year
three
two
one oh
can we leave our like this is where they
are yeah no because is that on the fence
yeah if you have to take one side what
would you think i disagree i don't think
they will i don't think they look i
think they're as close as they'll ever
get they're a brilliant bunch i think
they've done brilliant last two
tournaments but i just think when it
gets we cut to the chase
i look i i hope so because they deserve
to gareth deserves to and this group of
players dude got to a semi-final in the
world cup didn't they got to it a final
fan of your rose yeah is this the time
yeah i look at the squad and i just
think
i just think france germany spain
you've got brazil's argentina's coming
into it and all sort of you know senegal
all these countries are fantastic i
still think they're a couple years away
when the likes of bennyland get in the
team
find a
a role for do you think alexander should
go yes he's the most underrated player
in the premier league
and people say maybe not have the
mobility but he's just i like him he
works hard yeah he's always seven out of
ten without great right foot
you know what you're not letting him
down not let him down but because he's
so good at free kicks mike you're your
mate david beckham because he's so good
people forget all the other stuff he
does yeah and that's his problem but
he's top player we're on the same page
united's travel in 1999
is the greatest achievement by an
english cub three
two
one
i've got to strongly agree
i have to you that
99 was just
i was moving between agreeing strongly
because i kept thinking like leicester
winning the league is like
that's still the most bizarre thing of
all time but all the great teams the
liverpool teams the great arsenal teams
the great city teams now none of them
have done it so to do it
i think i have to agree
with all three trophies won the world
cup championship as well so it's good
you can't remember
yeah why that's not mickey mouse it's a
big trophy it's a mickey mouse of mickey
mouse trophy all the trophies you want
to claim that do you know to win that
trophy go on you've got to win the
champions league yeah we won the league
we won the champions league
i fake up
well no to get into the world club
championship you've got to do a bit
you've got to do it i'm a great i'm i'm
agreeing with you that team as well
though
cole and york
social
sharing them
yeah that was a are you in league one
then
you're a great thought were you
[Laughter]
yeah it's pretty hard to disagree with
us we don't need to disagree with that
no matter tonight players would
certainly make it into man's cities
starting 11. agree
i'll be really honest about it i can go
through them
diaz laporte concello walker
better than all united's back four
midfield fernandinho rodriguez rodriguez
better the united holding midfield
players
uh bernardo silva gundogan
bruno is the only one bruno is the only
one i think could could over last 12 to
18 months
but
de bruyne
bernardo silva mares
folding
sterling
i can't put i can't put bruno in front
of bernardo silva and at the moment and
then
and de bruyne
i can't i'd just be at the agreement
with you it's a sad indictment really
i think pogba on his day though i think
pogba i don't know
are we talking about form are we talking
about potential are we disagree but you
can't put your glasses don't start don't
don't start trying to do what you do
around paul pogba
what
if you think that strongly about it and
defend it
you can't put pogba i'm going to say you
can't put pogba
i'm going to disagree
and say all over the place
ronaldo ronaldo
from history or is it now as the plane
now 11 current 11 now as the play-in
no problem honestly i'm right i could
even be here if ronaldo was in city's
team he'd he'd all be on 20 25 i'm not
saying he wouldn't i'll take ronaldo off
you
good swap
who's dropping himself
that wasn't the key
it's a good question the journalists
from the uh
from the outside over here which are you
dropping foden sterling
mahrez de bruyne i'm only going two in
midfield oh he's bottled it
i'm going 4-2-3-1 oh my god he's changed
pep's played 4-3-3 for last 25 years
and mike has bottled it and changed his
system
oh my god i'm going four two three one
right now yeah
it has to be it's imperative check it
out it's it is imperative that ronaldo's
in my second life who are you checking
out rodri's out roger i'm going i'm
going to yeah that's what i'm going only
to get ronaldo in that's what i'm doing
pep guardiola has had a bigger impact on
football than sir alex ferguson
three
two
one
horrible that one is this is this the
fence line here is this sitting right on
the fence
fergie's the old time great what are you
moving it to no i can't i can't
disrespect him like that i can't
disrespect the great sir alex
like that peppa's been unbelievable and
he's changed the game pep's coming to
the premier league
and everyone thought he can't play the
bastard style of play they can play it
and they've dominated he's changed the
way football is seen in this country
without doubt but sir alex ferguson
people say he's not the greatest
tactician but he said know how
i
i would have to disagree with that now
and only because as well pep's not won
the champions league if you have this
conversation in two three years it might
be different but i've got to disagree
with you i think peps
pep's global impact
sorry barcelona in spain
munich germany and influenced the whole
of german football now he's influenced
all of our football
it is unbelievable like i i've never
seen really anybody as good in terms of
the influence that he's had but when you
put sir alex's longevity at united and
then the thing for me that balances it
out my disagree is scotland
aberdeen taking on rangers and celtic
and winning and beating real madrid in
european finals so for me i think to do
that in scotland the impact he had up
there and down here we're on the same
page here mate same page
keane and richards are a better punditry
jewel oh my god don't if you don't even
need to ask no
me and keno
you can't be beaten
we've talked the we've elevated the
punditry to our next level
you know what i mean human humility
[Laughter]
no
in terms of
the top the top people are in in sky i'm
not gonna i work for bbc and cbs i've
got to keep watching absolutely you know
what i mean
you you wouldn't you were never the best
you know that yeah on a monday on monday
you and cara sorry you and carla are the
best on monday night football brilliant
i don't think there's any
they're better they're better if you
don't listen to the words
[Laughter]
and the better look at
when carol and neb were coming into him
i didn't like each other to start the
gym really because he was obviously
united liverpool so i was thinking how's
this dynamic going to work
and then to still manage to keep the
same level
to what i was used to as a kid growing
up
i think that's testament to both of you
so i would say
in terms of the big hit is you two the
big hitters i'll say agree
because i think to be fair
super sunday pulse match sunday evening
i put them to on
in the studio
monday night
i put us two on friday night was because
if it's sunday night they they work
together i think that to be fair i get a
bit tired at half six on a sunday
personally as well you know
you know the idea they've done the
commentary walking back around to the
studio no see i think there's certain
aspects of when
you know i'm not a great fan of being in
the studio or sitting in the studio but
you like that dawn i love it was i like
being in the commentary i like being
involved in the game i like being
involved in the monday night football
analysis so i think i will agree with it
because i'm going to go super sunday i
would say yeah
and then put one of us in with you maybe
you know i mean i'll gray i mean it's it
works but i think you two are strong on
a sunday man united man city sunday
afternoon 4 30 you two are in there i
think number one and two
now i might be on the commentary with
carrie you know what i mean or whatever
but i think i generally i would agree
and i'm basing it on the fact that i
think certain shows you are better
because i think people want to want
different things at different times of
the week
yeah
they don't want analysis on the sunday
afternoon after a game they want strong
opinion strong opinion fun hard hitting
comments and you know that sort of big
stuff
we
he said you were the best pundit and
then very swiftly changed his mind to
himself
gary neville would make a brilliant
prime minister
three
two
one this is no this is it's not
we're not saying for fun the comments
you make on twitter
you've been there and you've worked in
different industries
and you speak from the heart with
passion so i would agree i don't know if
you're honest at not because
everyone claims
[Laughter]
so i would strongly agree with that no
i'm saying disagree because i just
couldn't do politics i don't think are
you part of the labour party i know what
politics is different than being part of
a member of a party or speaking on
twitter it's like being in there having
to negotiate with different people and
listen to people
i disagree no i think you're not backing
yourself i agree when michael was a
youngster he burst onto the scene
without doubt i burst on the scene
honestly can we look people like people
laugh at this people laugh do you know
what i mean but if you play for your
country at 18
and you know like the games to get there
as well i think it was like 20 odd games
i've only played first team football and
i was in the england team i remember the
debut against robin robin's saying oh
yeah chelsea we need to buy him and all
that was 20 million pounds worth
15 years ago i'm not they disagree with
you i thought on that night you had a
good argument with roy yes just pro
problem for you as you burst off the
seat
it was quick
you first done it stopped it
525 was done
good luck for the darby sir good luck
gary neville is the best
one
[Laughter]
i know i just i don't like it